the changing landscape reflects efforts
to halt the climate emergency
drive around britain and you can see it
for yourself but what about
our individual habits at the services i
met a trio of environmentalists heading
to wales in their hybrid car
to go walrus spotting they don't need
any convincing the planet is in peril
people's attitudes is like they can't be
bothered an exclusive yougov poll for
sky news showed nearly a quarter of
people
are not prepared to change a single key
climate habit
this includes things like never driving
a petrol or diesel car again
or paying more to fly abroad
for now none of us are actually allowed
to holiday overseas
but heading into wales to the fonty gary
leisure park
gareth and merwin evans admit
convenience
not climate concerns guide their travel
plans
we're concerned about climate change but
its
impact on us is negligible
the yougov poll found more than
two-thirds of people
don't feel personally impacted by
climate change
we might not realize that climate change
affects us all
or be prepared to make the changes
needed
but the poll shows a growing realisation
of some of the issues driving the
climate emergency
the high percentage of people understand
the definition of climate issues
such as carbon footprint and renewable
energy
but much lower recognition of terms like
the cop climate conference
and its president and climate minister
alok sharma do you know who this is
no alex sharma
david is worried the government could
end sales of bikes like his
that bike is it diesel petrol but it
goes like
well i wouldn't want electric bike they
too slow when they only last
five away with two young children who
are
going to be around and obviously see the
effects climate change is have
probably more than we will in my
lifetime friends of the earth say the
messaging on climate policies
needs to change i think the emphasis
does need to be on
on the benefits that are to be gained
from
um from tackling climate change
they're endless really when when you
start to think about it
in this pivotal year for the climate not
everyone is yet on board on the uk's
journey
to net zero lisa holland sky news barry